estelle bonjour alors comment est la
situation dans les commerces autour de
vous quelle est l'atmosphère
eh bien écoutez olivier il ya la queue
pour rentrer dans certains commerces
tels cas derrière moi dans ses
supermarchés de boulogne billancourt des
filtrages ont été mises en place à
l'entrée à des magasins pour éviter
qu'il n'y ait trop de monde à
l'intérieur on rentre donc au compte
gouttes ce qui permet et bien de
respecter les mesures barrières
préconisé et notamment la distanciation
social alors ceux à qui nous avons pu
parler ici à craignent un confinement
total et ont décidé de faire avec
quelques réserves sans pour autant céder
à la panique je vous propose de les
écouter on a des rumeurs sur des
chimistes cinq semaines six semaines
enfin voila j'ai comme ça tout seul pas
tout seul chez soi a pas sans tache et
soissons pour faire quelques courses et
tout c'est ça va être compliqué mais bon
après je préfère ça que d'avoir une
épidémie qui se répand et d'avoir des
dizaines voire des centaines de milliers
de morts quoi c'est normal de faire ça
c'est de rester sereins on a deux
enfants à la maison qui sont quittes
section ces peines ont fait l'école à la
maison
le télétravail les cours sont c'était
déjà un petit peu organisés
elle anticipait plus pouvoir sortir
comme un petit moment on s'adapte on
n'achète pas masquer moi on est quand
même tu peux prévenant pour essayer
d'avoir quelques réserves parce qu'on ne
sait pas qu'est ce qu'il en est donc on
essaie d'avoir ce qu'il faut voilà hier
le ministre de l'économie à bruno le
maire a rappelé qu'il n'y avait pas de
risque de pénurie de produits
alimentaires en france des mesures de
sécurité ont été prises pour assurer les
approvisionnements at il assuré
merci beaucoup estelle est el farj en
direct de boulogne billancourt dans les
hauts de seine